le variant delta continue sa progression
et vitesse éclair en france
face à ce rebond le gouvernement
s'active le projet de loi concernant les
nouvelles mesures sanitaires validé hier
en conseil des ministres et à
l'assemblée nationale le texte sera
débattu dès demain dans l'hémicycle
avant d'arriver au sénat jeudi
deux grands axes vaccination obligatoire
des soignants et extension du pass est
sanitaire cet après midi le premier
ministre annonce et qu'il saisira le
conseil constitutionnel pour en parler
on retrouve à l'assemblée nationale
notre reporter katia technique
katia bon soir le projet de loi est
actuellement entre les mains des députés
de la commission des lois qui ont
auditionné le ministre de la santé liés
géant mais absolument il a été
auditionné à 14 heures ils affichent une
grande détermination vis-à-vis du projet
de loi sanitaire justifiant le fait
qu'il s'agisse de mesures
exceptionnelles alors selon lui le pass
sanitaire est l'équivalent d'un
dispositif médical etc soit le pinceau
sanitaire dans son esprit soit le
confinement ou encore la fermeture des
grands centres commerciaux
s'il ya une flambée de l'épidémie il a
justifié la prolongation de l'état
d'urgence à décembre parce que selon lui
concept en mai bien rien ne sera fini il
a été reproché au ministre durant cette
audition un peu plus tard dans
l'hémicycle que le passé littérale être
imposée alors que tous les français qui
le souhaitent ne peuvent pas être
vaccinés
certaines ars même cessé de prendre des
rendez vous est à cela il n'y a pas eu
beaucoup d'explications de justification
si ce n'est que des millions de doses
vont être livrés et jean castex a assuré
que l'objectif de 40 millions de primo
vaccinait serait atteint à la fin
juillet en tout cas comme vous le disiez
la situation est inquiétante dix huit
mille nouveaux cas ces dernières 24
heures et d'augmentations exponentielle
donc pour olivier ferrand il n'y a pas
de doute justement ce n'est plus le
temps du doute
on écoute olive et veyran durant
l'audition les scientifiques nous le
dise si nous fermions tous les
établissements comme nous l'avons fait
pendant le confinement pour tous les
français l'impact épidémique et
sanitaire serait le même que si nous
fermions l'ensemble de ces
établissements pour les seuls non
vaccinés
la vaccination est une chance la
vaccination est un droit mais ça peut
aussi devenir un devoir et même une
responsabilité
pas d'exception pas de passager
clandestin nous voulons du collectif du
collectif du collectif pour atteindre
l'immunité et se débarrasser du virus
il ne faut pas nous nous méprendre ce
n'est pas le pass alitée ou la liberté
la question c'est le passé ni terre ou
le confinement
certains sénateurs opposés au projet de
loi sanitaire vont saisir le conseil
constitutionnel est bien le premier
ministre jean castex aussi on les écoute
je voudrais dire à la représentation
nationale que sur l'ensemble du texte
dont vous êtes désormais saisie je
saisirai le conseil constitutionnel car
n'en doutez pas notre objectif comme
toujours a été de prendre des mesures
proportionnées à la situation sanitaire
garantissant les libertés publiques
fondamentales et assurant le
développement de la sécurité sanitaire
à noter donc à l'issue d'une journée
d'auditions et de questions au
gouvernement
la fermeté de l'exécutif vis-à-vis des
mesures du projet de loi sanitaire avant
les débats de demain à l'assemblée qui
risque d'être houleux en effet des
députés de droite comme de gauche
contestent les privations de liberté
qu'induit le passé ni terre 4 ça pique
nique en direct depuis l'assemblée
nationale merci beaucoup pour tout ces
précisions